morgan freeman may be known for his
narration in films like shawshank
redemption and march of the penguins but
there's one movie the oscar winner
refused to lend his silky smooth pipes
to keep watching to learn which one and
a whole lot more
after a handful of tiny roles in films
and tv shows in the early 70s and a
stint on the electric company morgan
freeman didn't really break out as an
actor until the late 1980s with a couple
of oscar-nominated performances in
street smart and driving miss daisy
freeman was well into his 50s by the
time he achieved household name status
but that doesn't mean he didn't have a
lifelong love of acting raised by his
grandparents in mississippi freeman
landed roles in many school plays and
even won a statewide acting competition
at the age of 14. he pursued theater
with such skill and intensity that by
the time he was ready to graduate high
school he landed a drama scholarship to
jackson state university astoundingly
freeman passed on the quick entry to the
next level of acting ironically
freeman's love for movies almost sent
him on an entirely different career path
freeman's enthusiasm for cinematic
depictions of mid-air military combat
inspired him to enlist in the u.s air
force in 1955.
i wanted to be
in the military i wanted to be a fighter
pilot i wanted to fly airplanes
after four years he left the service
upon realizing life as a fighter pilot
wasn't going to be as cool and exciting
as hollywood had led him to expect
it may be tough to imagine but the same
guy who partnered up with clint eastwood
to assassinate two cowboys in unforgiven
was serenading children with songs a
couple of decades earlier to help teach
them lessons about reading and nutrition
between 1971 and 1977 freeman appeared
daily on the electric company the show
was something of a companion program to
sesame street and it was meant for
children too old for the more well-known
program of the characters freeman played
the most well-remembered is easyreader a
hipster who would get intensely excited
at the prospect of reading anything from
a storefront sign to the ingredients on
a soda bottle he also played mel mounds
the dj and vincent the vegetable vampire
speaking to rich eisen in 2017 freeman
said he was initially terrified to get
involved with the electric company
because he worried that getting too
heavily identified with children's
television would exclude other
opportunities freeman told eisen if that
show had kept going i might still be
there
if you ask people the movie they most
associate morgan freeman with you're
likely to hear about seven or the
shawshank redemption but ironically the
part freeman regularly calls his
breakthrough role is perhaps the one
he's least remembered for at least
outside critics circles
it took over 20 years but the actor
finally earned fame and his first oscar
nomination for best supporting actor
with 1987's crime drama street smart in
street smart freeman plays the pimp fast
black who's locked in a battle of wits
with jonathan fisher played by
christopher reeve a magazine reporter
who'd been writing fictional stories
about prostitution and selling them off
as the real thing to save his flagging
career at the time of the film's release
the new yorker's pauline kale was ahead
of the curve starting her review of
street smart with the question is morgan
freeman america's greatest living actor
while it took freeman until the age of
50 to make it he doesn't seem to feel at
all bitter about the journey pointing
out in a 2011 interview
didn't have to happen at all
while doing press for dolphin tale 2
freeman called his roland street smart
his favorite of all his parts
fast black was about as far away from me
as i can get in terms of acting it was
more alien to who i really am
in a 1996 talk with interview magazine
morgan freeman said it was in part his
work on 1992's unforgiven that drove him
to make his directorial debut with the
critically hailed bopa the following
year set in south africa during the time
of the apartheid bopa stars danny glover
as micah a tough but fair policeman
who's hoping his son will follow in his
footsteps while micah believes his place
on the police force is to the benefit of
black south africans as the film
progresses he sees the way his white
colleagues work and he begins to
question his beliefs while critics liked
bopa the box office was less impressed
which may have something to do with why
freeman's only directing work since has
been a few episodes of the political
drama madam secretary it could also be
because freeman's experience on bopa was
marred by interfering studio executives
freeman told interview that the only
thing about directing bopa that wasn't
rewarding was dealing with studio
executives who were making decisions
thousands of miles away
one of the most iconic aspects of morgan
freeman's career has less to do with
anything you've seen him in and more to
do with what you've heard him in as
graham norton put it when freeman
appeared on his talk show it was
freeman's memorable narration of 1994's
the shawshank redemption that made him
mister narration
i hope people stop asking me to do
stupid voice overs like
after the shawshank redemption freeman's
voice was in high demand and 2005 proved
a particularly busy year for freeman in
the sound booth that year he narrated
the pbs docu-series slavery and the
making of america the documentary film
march of the penguins and steven
spielberg's war of the worlds his voice
has also been used on the waze
navigation app and it replaced walter
cronkite's voice in the introduction for
cbs evening news in 2010. this is the
cbs evening news with katie curry when
jimmy kimmel asked freeman about the
secret to his voice in 2016 the actor
said he didn't have any kind of special
technique simply citing his voice and
diction lessons in college but he was a
little bit more open six years earlier
while doing press for dolphin tale
freeman said that if you want your voice
to sound more impressive you've got to
yawn a lot pressed a bit further freeman
explained
it relaxes your vocal cords and once
they're relaxed the tone drops the lower
your voice is the better you sound
in 2009 morgan freeman starred in
invictus as nelson mandela the
anti-apartheid revolutionary who was
released from prison after nearly three
decades in 1990 and became the president
of south africa four years later
invictus was a critical success and
freeman earned an oscar nomination for
best actor while co-star matt damon was
nominated for best supporting actor
making invictus was a journey freeman
started almost 15 years earlier during a
press conference for his 1995
autobiography long walk to freedom
nelson mandela said morgan freeman was
his choice for lead actor for any
potential adaptations
in 2009 freeman told the griot that was
the moment he warmly accepted that he
would eventually play mandela
freeman met with mandela not long after
and asked to have access to the south
african president in order to give the
role as authentic a portrayal as
possible and mandela agreed but getting
a script wasn't easy freeman said he and
his production partner laurie mccreery
tried to adapt long walk to freedom but
that it was difficult to present the
entire scope of mandela's story into a
two-hour movie the breakthrough came
with john carlin's 2006 book proposal
for what would become playing the enemy
nelson mandela and the game that made a
nation according to freeman the story
about the south african rugby team at
the 1995 rugby world cup perfectly
captured mandela freeman told the griot
for us this was the film to give the
world insight into who mandela is and
how he operates
in 1994 morgan freeman starred in the
shawshank redemption as red the best
friend of the wrongly imprisoned andy
dufresne played by tim robbins and one
of shawshank penitentiary's most
well-known smugglers in spite of the
film bombing commercially it's gone on
to become a regular feature on any list
of the most inspirational films or
movies that'll make you cry amazingly
freeman almost turned the role down the
film is based on rita hayworth and the
shawshank redemption from stephen king's
1982 collection different seasons
in 2014 freeman told yahoo entertainment
that he was sent the book after being
offered the role explaining
and i read the first page and read was
this irishman so i closed the book i
never read another line i was like i
can't play an irishman thankfully
freeman ultimately didn't let that stop
him and we got to see him in one of his
best roles a bit of a wink was put in
the script acknowledging the ethnicity
change when dufresne asks freeman's
character why everyone calls him red he
answers
maybe it's because i'm irish
morgan freeman and clint eastwood
famously starred as aging gunslingers
going on one last job in the practically
flawless film unforgiven
eastwood directed this 1992 western and
ever since the pair have expressed
nothing but confidence and kinship
toward one another
i think the best
of them all
certainly for me
is clint eastwood
in 2004 freeman starred in another
eastwood directed feature the
heartbreaking sports drama million
dollar baby and got his first oscar win
for his efforts and when it came time
for freeman to realize his goal of
playing nelson mandela in a movie with
2009's invictus his choice for director
was clear
he told the seattle times that when
producer laurie mccleary asked him what
director he wanted freeman answered i
can only think of two clint eastwood and
then there's clint eastwood he's the
best director i know
freeman praised eastwood's directing
style in a number of interviews usually
pointing to his hands-off style in
dealing with actors he told the seattle
times eastwood can stand back and let
them do their thing then take all the
credit
known for his distinctive soothing
authoritative voice morgan freeman has
landed a lot of voice over and narration
work serving as the de facto all-knowing
metaphorical voice of god in the
shawshank redemption and march of the
penguins led to freeman's playing the
personification of the christian idea of
god in the blockbuster comedies bruce
almighty and evan almighty one film in
which freeman didn't play god was seth
rogen and evan goldberg's star-studded
apocalyptic comedy this is the end rogan
and goldberg wrote a part just for
freeman but he turned it down rogan told
yahoo entertainment we wanted him to
play god apparently he takes his
character as god very seriously
the 2000 historical golf drama the
legend of bagger vance is another big
movie that was designed to include
freeman at one point initially director
robert redford planned to star in the
film himself alongside freeman then he
changed his mind and decided to cast the
younger actors matt damon and will smith
instead
during the me too movement that rocked
hollywood in 2017 and 2018 in which
inappropriate and criminal behaviors of
powerful men were rooted out and made
public two women accused morgan freeman
of unprofessional behavior of a physical
nature according to cnn a production
assistant who worked on freeman's movie
going in style in 2015 alleged that the
actor touched and rubbed her and
commented on her body and attire almost
daily and repeatedly tried to lift her
skirt the latter behavior stopped only
when co-star alan arkin told freeman to
quit it
cnn also reported that a member of the
production staff of the 2012 film now
you see me alleged sexual harassment of
herself and a female assistant according
to abc 7 new york freeman responded to
the allegations with a 10-page letter
issued by his lawyer demanding a
retraction and apology from cnn the
letter stated in part
cnn's report is a product of malicious
intent falsehoods sleight of hand and
absence of editorial control and
journalistic malpractice
later on freeman apologized to quote
anyone who felt uncomfortable or
disrespected a year and a half after
freeman feuded with cnn the cable
network hired him to narrate a video for
parent company warner media's investor
presentation a move that one cnn staffer
called disgusting if you or anyone you
know has been a victim of sexual abuse
help is available visit the rape abuse
and incest national network website or
contact reigns national helpline at
1-800-656-hope
[Music]